[Music]
wild horses
welcome back to cbs saturday morning we
begin this half hour with a roundup out
west the federal government is
corralling some of the 82 thousand wild
horses living on public lands in 10
western states well it might conjure up
thoughts of the old west it is the
modern technology the government is
using that is controversial
joy benedict has the story
it is a calm that's blanketed this
hillside since the west was one but just
after dawn on this summer day in the
high desert of northern california it
was the hum of machine that sliced
through the silence
on the range this is the sound of
controversy for man and mustang some
horses here in twin peaks
were raised on the range for the u.s
cavalry jeff fontana has been working
these lands for more than 30 years with
the federal bureau of land management
it's charged with caring for america's
wild horses they're living symbols of
the historic and pioneer spirit of the
west but with an estimated 82 thousand
of them running free in 10 states this
year alone the bureau known as blm is
tasked with slimming the herds by 20
thousand horses and burros we've been
using helicopters for most of the
program and really helicopters are a
safe and efficient way to move large
numbers of animals across the landscape
as the chopper descends on a group of
horses it pushes in pulls back pushes in
again eventually corralling them into a
trap but how dangerous is this for them
well injuries occur you know we're
talking about wild horses wild animals
that have never been around humans but
our track record is really good in this
program injuries resulting in death
from our gather activities
are less than one half of one percent
but of course you have to understand how
traumatizing or sad it is for the public
to see you lose any horse
sure it's also a situation we're trying
to avoid losing horses on the range due
to degraded resources
and while it's hard to imagine the
overpopulation of anything out here
that's what the blm says is happening we
try and keep the herd at the at the
right size or else we're going to have
animals that don't have food to eat or
water to drink jason leuterman works for
the national horse and burro program
it's operating 46 roundups in the west
this year including this one in
california wild horse and burro herds
increase at 15 to 20 percent a year if
we weren't here to manage that growth
the herds will keep growing eventually
they will degrade the land enough to
where they will
run out of food and water so you're
basically saying that you manage the
herd to keep the herd that's exactly
right yep our goal is to manage healthy
herds on healthy public lands and so the
way we can do that is to make sure that
there's enough resources out here for
those animals to survive
the blm manages 26.9 million acres of
land established in the 1940s to oversee
and preserve federal lands and lease
them for lucrative livestock grazing but
when wild mustang started being hunted
congress passed the wild free-roaming
horses and burro act in 1971
to protect them and the land they live
on the charge of of the government the
blm is to humanely manage and there's
nothing humane about what's going on
congresswoman dina titus a democrat from
nevada has initiated a formal review of
what the blm is doing it wasn't until
some of the activist groups started
tracking those roundups and taking video
of them that i realized just how
horrendous they are they use helicopters
they run horses down she also introduced
a bill to ground the choppers which last
year were used in roundups where 25
horses died she says there may be a more
humane method
they charge a high rate i say if you
don't use helicopters you can hire a
cowboy so save a horse and hire a cowboy
they know how to round up horses and i'm
sure it's more humane than this
the bureau of land management spent more
than 450 million dollars in the last
five years on its wild horse and bureau
program 25 million went to gathering
animals but most of the money goes to
caring for horses in long-term captivity
unadopted animals are cared for
long-term in what we call off-range
pastures these are big open grasslands
for these animals to roam for the rest
of their lives and yes it does cost
about 60 percent of our budget to care
for the unadopted and unsold animals and
although the horses are up for adoption
that program is drawing concern as well
as the blm only monitors adopted horses
for the first year
we don't place them in private ownership
if we believe that people have the
intent to sell them for slaughter and we
try to monitor that as best we can but
still it does happen it's it's happened
you know i can't can't deny that those
kinds of things have happened it's
something that we're acutely aware of
and always on top of and as for using
cowboys to round up mustangs they
stopped doing that back in the 70s and
i've talked to people who worked in the
program prior to the use of helicopters
and and moving horses with from
horseback was just a really really
difficult situation
but on this morning the bureau of land
management collected 46 horses including
six foals most of the animals were sent
to temporary holding facilities except
two a vet euthanized them for poor
health and although a handful of these
horses will receive birth control and be
released the rest will now live a
domestic life off the range and away
from the land that once made them wild
and free
for cbs saturday morning joy benedict on
the twin peaks range in lassen county
california
such beautiful animals they really are
majestic it's been an issue for a long
time and nobody's been able to figure
out the one solution that works for
everything there's no easy answer but
when you do hear about managing the herd
to keep the herd it goes a long way in
talking about the challenges that
they're facing yeah alrighty